salut à tous je m'appelle marie de bro
ar je suis journaliste et là je passe
quelques jours en vacances en toscane
pour pour nous reposer un peu j'avais
pris mes billets avant le coc vie d'un
ligament
je suis arrivé ici en avion et juste
avant de prendre mon vol hier j'avais la
dalle de ouf
du coup bah je suis allé dans une
boulangerie j'ai demandé deux croissants
et là la boulangère elle m'a regardé
comme ça elle m'a dit deux croissants
vous êtes sûr que c'est bon pour ce que
vous avez j'ai complètement buggé je me
suis dit mais qu'est ce que j'ai je
comprends pas bon bref je suis passé à
autre chose
j'entre dans l'avion et là je me
retrouve à une place horrible à entre
deux personnes d'un côté tu peux pas
regarder au hublot ce qui se passe et de
l'autre objet de soul et le boisé à
chaque fois que tu veux aller aux
toilettes
enfin bon heureusement ça dure et que
1h15 parce que j'avais là j'avais les
accoudoirs qui me rentrait dans les
bourrelets la ceinture qu'ils étaient
trop serrés à chaque fois que j'ai
fleuret la cuisse de mon voisin il
mettait des coups de coude en sang rare
c'est vraiment désagréable vespa rab
je passe à autre chose j'arrive à pise
suis trop contente
mais là je me rends compte que j'ai
complètement oublié de m'acheter un
short de plage genre un petit short
donc je vais dans une boutique en me
disant que peut-être peut-être à pise je
trouverais dans un short en taille 50
bah non pas du tout tout s'arrête aux 42
pour savoir que la taille moyenne des
femmes c'est 40 42 ans donc selon un
institut du l'institut français du
textile
donc c'est un peu con quand même je
trouve de s'arrêter ou 42 ne bronze pas
grave je passe à autre chose
mais cette journée là en fait c'est
toute ma vie parce qu'en fait le mont qu
en taille 50 il n'est pas fait pour ce
monde là ce monde là il n'est pas fait
pour les gros et les grosses notre
société elle est grosso fob la
grossophobie celle nom qui a été donné à
la discrimination que vivent les
personnes grosses au quotidien c'est pas
il faut bijoux j'ai peur des bourrelets
non c'est par exemple le fait que des
jeunes femmes
sa femme parce qu'elles ont l'impression
de pas être dans la norme ou qu'elles
ont peur de grossir
c'est le fait que quand on regarde quand
on regarde un film et qui est un
personnage gros
c'est un looser qui mangent de la junk
food sur son canapé toute la journée
c'est ça la grossophobie et c'est pour
ça que je suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour
vous raconter mon histoire de femmes
grosses et puis cet été des solutions
bas peut-être que vous pourrez m'aider
parce que la grossophobie elle est
partout tout le temps de l'enfance à
l'âge adulte
quand on est une petite fille grosse ou
que juste on est un tout petit peu au
dessus de la moyenne la sur le carnet de
santé est bon nous parle de notre poids
tout le temps
les adultes sont vraiment là pour nous
rappeler que ça va pas et les enfants
nous harcèlent parce que les adultes
auront dit qu'être gros ça va pas faut
savoir que l'âge moyen du premier régime
ses 8 ans 8 ans est très très jeune
c'est quand même en pleine croissance
moi là par exemple ça c'est une photo de
moi à 10 ans est-ce que sincèrement vous
ne trouvez grosse que moi j'ai plutôt
l'impression que ça va quoi mais à cet
âge là dans ma tête
vraiment j'étais persuadé que j'étais
pas dans la norme que ça allait pas du
tout et encore personnellement j'ai eu
de la chance je me suis construite une
bonne carapace j'ai fait des bonnes
blagues sur mon poids en étant bien
drôle
bon ça a ses limites l'autodérision en
permanence parce que c'est pas dingue
dingue pour le stim de soi mais j'ai eu
la chance de ne pas être harcelé à
l'école parce que selon l' oms les
enfants obèses ont 63 % plus de risques
d'être harcelée scolairement et quand on
se fait humilier insulté frappé
uniquement parce qu'on est gros le
rapport aux autres la santé
psychologique
le rapport à son corps tout ça ça
devient très vite compliqué puis on
grandit on grossit on veut avoir des
amoureux des amoureuses avoir des
relations quoi et puis on regarde des
films des romances à la télé évidemment
les héros et héroïnes sont minces on
nous fait des bonnes blagues utile et
quelle est la différence entre une
grosse dame et v pantoufles aucune
on est bien dedans ne sort pas avec
sympathique et les gants classe
moi je suis sur les applications de
rencontres depuis que j'ai 17 ans j'en
ai 25
du coup je voulais vous juste vous
montrez de trois messages que j'ai reçus
j'adore tes gros seins ok j'ai jamais
couché avec une meuf ronde clin d'oeil
lubrique toi qui a l'air d'aimer la
bouffe
tu dois bien su c'est même pas un bon
jour quoi sympathique élégant classe
ok donc dans les films je suis jamais
l'héroïne qui tombe amoureuse du héros
et dans ma vie privée dans son
application de rencontre mon corps est
un espèce de fantasme qui seraient
détachés de ma tête quasiment et bas que
ça on appelle ça la fétichisation décor
gros c'est à dire que comme je suis une
femme grosse je serai plus vulnérables
ou genre super dominatrice je coucherais
avec qui veut bien parce que de toute
manière je vais pas avoir beaucoup
d'occasions
je dois être super gourmande au lit et
tout ça en fait c'est grosso fab bail
parce que que l'on trouve que tous les
corps gros soit sont absolument
dégueulasse ou être obsédé par la
grosseur dans ses rapports sexuels c'est
pas hyper chouette surtout pour nous les
gros et les grosses donc bon l'amour le
sexe le sexe ça va être compliqué on
grandit encore on grossit encore et les
temps de trouver du taf
évidemment ça coince encore les clichés
sur les gros dans le milieu du travail
il y en a vraiment plein les gros on
serait mon dynamique on aurait moins
d'énergie ne serait même plus bête ces
surplus tas de graisse manta de cerveau
c'est vraiment logique donc en fait t'es
pas apte à travailler on ne donne pas de
travail c'est vraiment le sable le
serpent qui se mord la queue quoi faut
savoir que la grossophobie c'est une des
discriminations principal que subissent
les françaises et les français dans le
monde du travail
selon l'observatoire des discriminations
par exemple moi demain je vais être
hôtesse d'accueil pour un gros événement
genre tedx divise en sept voire huit mes
chances d'avoir un entretien d'embauché
juste parce que physiquement ça se voit
sur la photo que je suis obèses et pour
les métiers de bureau c'est pas rien il
ya trois à quatre fois moins de chance
c'est un peu moins mais c'est toujours
voilà c'est toujours un petit problème
est par exemple c'est exactement pareil
pour l'accès aux promotions ou
l'évolution dans la carrière il ya même
pire on est même moins payés jean
françois amadieu que directeur
de l'observatoire des discriminations a
écrit qu aux etats unis une femme qui
pèse 30 kg de plus qu'une autre est payé
en moyenne 9% de moins de salaire et
j'ai bien les femmes parce qu'on tolère
un tout petit peu plus les kilos en trop
chez les hommes mais c'est vraiment un
tout petit peu plus et tout ça c'est
vraiment pareil en france un bon ok donc
l'espace public c'est compliqué l'enfant
s'est compliqué la vie amoureuse c'est
compliqué le travail c'est compliqué bon
ben il me reste plus qu'une solution
bah oui c'est d'aller chez le médecin
puisque obésité égale maladie maladie
égale aller se faire soigner chez le
médecin et qu'est ce qu'on dit quand je
chez le médecin madame manger sainement
et fait du sport parce que sinon ben
sinon quoi sinon vous allez mourir
ah d'accord elle aime expliquer à quel
moment du serment d'hippocrate c'était
marqué traumatisé vos patients sans
essayer de leur donner une seule
solution ou bien de comprendre ce qu'il
va pas dans leur dit j'ai du louper un
passage mais parce que vous pensez quoi
vous pensez que c'est un choix de vie
que j'ai vous pensez que j'ai pas essayé
de maigrir parce qu'il fallait le dire
sinon je ne me serais pas fait chier à
avoir des carottes râpées sans sauce à
chaque fois qu'il y avait une soirée
raclette quand j'avais 18 ans bah ouais
parce que la plupart du temps quand on
va chez le médecin et qu'on est gros
même si c'est pour une bronchite
on nous parle de notre poids on nous
humilient on nous rappelle les choses on
nous insulte
parce qu'il va falloir m'expliquer
pourquoi est ce que une gynécologue va
dire à une femme grosse que banon elle a
pas besoin de contraception vu comme
elle est laide et pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya des des gens à qui on dit d'aller
faire des irm dans des eaux
parce que ça n'existe pas leur taille
pourquoi est ce que les lits d'hôpitaux
ne supporte pas certains points pourquoi
est-ce qu'à chaque fois que je vais chez
le médecin on me dit que je vais mourir
sans jamais mais des noms parce que la
conséquence en fait de cette
grossophobie médicale dans le missouri
dans le milieu médical bas c'est simple
les gros et les grosses on va plus chez
le médecin on n'a pas accès à la santé
et aux soins comme tout le monde parce
qu'on a peur on a peur des médecins on a
peur de ce qu'ils vont nous dire on a
peur de comment ils vont nous le dire
dans les cabinets dans les cabinets
médicaux
nous écoute pas je suis grosse donc du
coup tous mes problèmes ville de là
c'est sûr merci au revoir quoi selon une
étude réalisée au connecticut ch college
nous les obèses on à 65% plus de risque
de vivre avec une maladie non
diagnostiquées comme un cancer bon je
vais pas vous déprimez trop longtemps je
vais pas non plus vous parlez de la
grossophobie sur femmes enceintes de la
grossophobie des troubles du
comportement alimentaire ou encore de
suicide ça commencerait peut-être à
faire un peu beaucoup pour aujourd'hui
moi je suis juste une meuf grosse
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour me montrer
parce que on nous voit tellement jamais
summers celui chaise
moi j'ai pas la solution l'obésité je
suis pas scientifique je suis pas
docteur mais contre la grossophobie la
solution elle est vraiment en chacun de
nous parce que la grossophobie elle elle
fait mal la grossophobie elle elle fait
elle rend malade la grossophobie elle
fait grossir la grossophobie elle tu es
donc vous inquiétez pas on est tous
grosso fob même moi je suis gros sauf au
bon gré parfois je dis des trucs c'est
complètement absurde
alors que j'en connais un rayon et je
connais le sujet mais juste il faut se
dire que quand on est gros ce n'est pas
de notre faute
il ya mille et un facteur pour lesquels
on peut grossir donc arrêtons de dire
aux gens qui seraient tellement plus
joli s'il perdait quelques kilos
arrêtons de culpabiliser les autres sur
ce qu'ils mangent arrêtons de
culpabiliser nous mêmes de se
culpabiliser sur ce qu'on mange
arrêtons de recommander des régimes
complètement absurde ça ça pourrit les
santé ça peut vraiment pourri la santé
soyons inclusif
si vous avez je sais pas moi si vous
avez le pouvoir de rendre l'espace
public accessible faites le si vous avez
une entreprise embaucher des personnes
grosses si vous avez une marque de
fringues fait du quadruple xl en fait il
faut être vraiment bienveillant soyons
bienveillant soyons de veilhan avec les
autres soyons de surveillants avec nous
mêmes parce que le vrai méchant dans
l'histoire c'est l'obésité est pas les
obèses merci de m'avoir écouté
[Musique]